how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation it is John and it is Roxy stryer
back once again for a momentous occasion
today we're tackling blade pre-mcu
another first time watch how are you
doing Roxy yeah are you ready to be
sharp as a blade
I am ready for more tremendous comedy
like that joke right there yeah this
movie should cut like a blade oh there
you go I have a long history with this
movie in that when I was a child I
begged and pleaded my mom and dad I
thought Wesley Snipes on the poster in
the calendar section the newspaper was
the absolute coolest I begged them to
take me to see blade they did and then
within like the first three minutes like
it was a bunch of blood and there was a
hand on my face and we were back in the
car so I have been waiting since 1998.
but guys don't let time pass between you
and leaving a like do that right now on
the video also subscribe hit the
notification Bell follow Roxy on the
social media and check out the world
girls all right give them some love over
on the YouTubes and anywhere else fine
contents are found that's the truth
leave your best blade puns
Cuts deep
cut two if you want to enjoy the full
length experience everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlight
reels come join us over at patreon.com
the real rejects you can sync up with
your own copy of Blade as well as a fun
time and without further ado
let's watch some blade
okay 67 came out in 98 TBT
foreign
for TBD was the thing
oh snap should get bit
oh no
whoa
oh damn
this is what Stephen Dorff is most
famous from right
seeing Boondocks Saints no it's Flannery
I guess it must be he used to do those
cigarette commercials those blue
cigarette commercials I'm sure he's
stoked that that's your memory of him
that's right man the big uh Stephen
Dorff fan over what are we doing here
I have a sneaking suspicion that this
isn't gonna be an actual date
yeah dang Let's Get It On
that looks like the combination of Hank
Azaria and Dennis Quaid
[Music]
The Bodyguard no the guy she's bringing
in here no he doesn't but I want to yes
and you good job
great establishment of the vibe I really
feel like I'm there
90s let things breathe Stanley Stanley
oh
oh my did he eat the oh my I I think he
tripping he's trying to figure out what
it is I wouldn't put anything in my
mouth to drift off me on a club ceiling
or you would that's what you're noticing
he licked it hands that's what I'm
saying like I wouldn't just lick a
random thing that whoa oh damn
foreign
[Laughter]
BYO blood
what an amazing scene this is
do you recall this at all no we were
definitely in the car before
[Laughter]
yeah
oh yeah
yeah Jesus
Jesus at daywalker
oh
damn so it just like disintegrated
dang that doesn't look bad that bad for
19.98. I think it looks amazing yeah
ah sweet we're gonna Jack you up make
them hurt bad yeah sure you are I kind
of like that one guy from Twilight
I never saw Twilight
wow him using this Blade the sound
effects sick yeah
oh
[Music]
that's right Zuma blade
oh how cool I saw that in the poster I
thought it was the coolest freaking
thing
yes
give my regards to frost
whoa so they rejuvenate or regenerate
we're still scream when they found them
stapled to a wall
still juicy I need you to refrain from
using that word about a body that's
crisped
I'm quoting The Mummy okay it's
different when it's a reference is it
no
three o'clock
I'm going to give me some distance I
just want you to come down and take a
look come on it's not a date it's always
a date
just a blood sample for the pericardium
yeah
let me ask you something no give rough
second thoughts about us oh God damn it
man one job
look I'm trying really it's over
oh snap
[Music]
oh no
oh
[Music]
so what happens to her what kind of
Vamps are these
oh
hey you three
guys like
someone he's carrying a civilian
oh that was a sick pullback
whoa dude
what what
yes
[Music]
she's good it's a very soft tarp
apparently I think it's because she's
now been bit by the vamp yeah maybe
she's extra durable
killed today
reminds me of my mama
thank you with allium
garlic
you get a lead on him no too bad
ouch I love garlic oh hold it
I don't think I've ever seen a vampire
movie where you have time after even bit
some of them as you know the genre has
grown there are a lot of different rules
about like totally some treat it like a
poison you can suck out some of it's
instantaneous I don't think I've ever
seen that how many died we don't have an
exact count we're having different
oh
Deacon Frost
you can come in now
hey hey
my blood these people are our food
not our allies or maybe I'm just the
first to say out loud what we've all
been thinking we have existed this way
for thousands of years
born
how can you be born a vampire I guess it
must be like if your mother gets bit
while you're in the womb or something I
don't know then what's the aging process
how do vampires procreate yeah I love
natural shows or movies make rules like
I love to know the lore like what works
in this universe yeah
essence of garlic give it to me I want
it so far the garlic and the silver
stuff is pretty cool very like classic
Vamp yeah but updated in a cool 90s way
Whistler says I'm building up a
resistance to the Sarah
yeah I figured that might happen
super garlic garlic sauce truffle garlic
so your belief is that the woman in the
beginning was his mom he was born a
vampire yeah but he's a day Walker yeah
like there's got to be something to do
with that that makes him the day Walker
security measure not Jennifer ham was on
it I know I was gonna say ain't no hand
no more I had to increase the dose it's
over 50 milligrams now that's getting
dangerous it's over nine thousand
oh yeah
so many neck injections
oh my god oh yeah he might be the
hottest guy of the 90s comment below yes
you met blade
silent jumper
I got my trusty Boomerang knife here
vampires they're hard to kill they tend
to regenerate and I'm supposed to
believe all this well you already met Mr
crispy at the hospital
so what do you use then Stakes crosses
crosses don't lose squat blades
there we go let's get that lore vampires
are severely allergic to Silver feed
them garlic and they're going to
anaphylactic shock and of course there's
always sunlight ultraviolet rays so
garlic in you does that not affect it
unless they bite you and then they go
into shock like if you ate garlic and
then they bite you yeah that's why they
do the injections goes into your blood
so or does it keep them away you guys
just patch me up and sent me on my way
vampire maze silver nitrate essence of
garlic
send them into shock you start getting
sensitive to Daylight fine you're
thirsty regardless of how much you had
to drink and I suggest you take that gun
and use it on yourself
I think she's interna now nah or not in
a way where she has to die every time I
would get thirsty I'd be like
turning
these archives are restricted to the
member
the ancient texts can never be
translated now with that attitude his
eyes are crazy cool you don't need to
shout
but you have to frost
what are you gonna do
say it wasn't you all right
you keep your eyes open
they're everywhere
but it's daytime
it's like parts of it feel like New York
parts that feel like la
totally
I feel like she's keeping her eyes open
she is
tattoos mean she's gonna get in anyway
oh vampire mace
no she turns her I wonder if you spray
that on somebody's not a vampire how
that would feel I'd probably think what
the [__] that why do I taste like
Italian
I'm sorry whoa whoa oh hold on hold on
hold on please
the front door was open
what do you say that you were kidnapped
last night ah
Curtis Webb he died don't worry about
that right now okay it's gonna be fine
because you're dead
that's right they own the cops what is
this garlic yeah yeah well he said it
would work against vampires who said I
was a vampire huh
nobody
how's everybody just getting into our
apartment
oh a
[Music]
vampires and he proves himself maybe his
master
not you Guillermo a vampire cattle brand
tell us what you got
what you got how do you think that we
fund this organization huh
I know this place it's a blood bank so
where were you taking it I don't know
what you're talking about
go [__] yourself
oh my God that is the biggest gun I
had to find a cure for myself
oh he's saying eventually it will get
you they've just like prolonged the
inevitable I guess I mean it's yeah it's
that possibility still that it could
still take hold
foreign
that's right man that's a vampire mark
means that there's a safe house around
here somewhere they're vampires shows
the doorman play in the corner outdated
the way they smell it's like a bad dream
they're worse things out tonight than
vampires like what me like me
that's right sick line
you have an invitation cuddle
that's how I get in places too that's
right man what list
[Music]
is
in the freezer
oh
this must have been a very painful shoot
when they keep watch their records
politics Finance real estate they
already own half of downtown it's the
prequel the daybreakers downtown
out down
90s user interface
blade was waiting for me don't worry
about it there's no problem
yeah so he's gonna turn him though
that's good right I think he's just
gonna drink oh I don't think he's gonna
turn now no he's not gonna kill him
yeah that's what I asked for
if I let you suck my tongue would you
thank me
what
is this must be that the record
I've never seen an image of this what's
that
oh it's nothing it's routine research
oh
oh no Baron harkonin
prophecy I'm not really sure
[Music]
foreign
you are not good at this large vampire
monstrosity Jabba The Vampire yeah Java
lamp
the pages from the book of rivers
was a vampire Bible vampable
oh
shots like this always make me dizzy
don't you remember me
uh whoa
nice nice all the roundhouse kicks
yeah if a little kid attacked you would
you beat them up I mean like a kid of
that age I guess I'd have to retaliate
somehow I don't know that's a great
question
what are the ethics how old does your
kid have to be
oh
take my arm man
remember
oh
play piano again it's weirder than mine
oh yeah
come to think of a blade
I owe you one
I'm expecting company
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh damn
is it a bad time
great line
dude whistler's a g hey
[Music]
I was gonna say how many pages of the
vampire Bible are left
whoa
CGI fire
oh boy
[Music]
oh no
come on yes
whoa
[Music]
[Laughter]
ah the whole time
face oh my God
damn
the train stops for no one and then no
words clearly yes
dude she's a hematologist
how often in real life do people get
neck shots or is that just a movie thing
I've never seen it you're one of them
aren't you
no I'm your worst nightmare you have a
lot of veins there though that was a
sick sequence again there's a lot of sex
sequences Blade's mother was attacked by
a vampire while she was pregnant and
he's got their strength this time
tomorrow all those wounds of his will be
healed damn he also inherited their
thirst yeah I was wondering about that
time's running out his body's starting
to reject it so far all my efforts to
find a cure of fail
baddest ass I had a family once wife two
daughters then a Drifter Came Calling
one evening tried to make me decide
which order they die in oh we killed as
many of them as we can find but it's
getting worse because of frost if
something happened in the vampire ranks
and it staked my life that son of a at
the center of it I'm just confused
because we established that all the
other most the vampires were born
vampires yeah
you know what I mean so why can't they
day walk like he can I guess maybe
vampires can just procreate
yeah maybe that yeah that's totally what
it is
thank you
[Music]
morning
whoa when was the last time you stopped
to appreciate a good Sunrise oh that's
right you were born of vampire so you
never had the pleasure have you damn
you're never going to be a pureblatt
hold them you will never rule out
oh
dude take this fangs
wow
[Music]
damn
there we go 90s fire yeah
must be some good ass foundation they
got I'm
[Laughter]
cool a lot of weapons are created on the
way to trying to find cures for things
do you think they're in love deep down
I'm just a little tight you know
oh
vanish wouldn't want our little friend
here to wind up on the back of a milk
cart now
oh my God I have fangs and claws are
retractable you think the humans will
ever accept a half breed like you
they can't
they're afraid of you you're an animal
you're a maniac I don't think that a
freak
crazy that the sunblock works I know I
want you with us
oh dang you're nothing to me
but another dead vampire yep you're an
idiot you know that nope you're gonna
wish they never cut you from your
mother's womb
whoa
whoa catch her
oh fine
oh
dang bus ain't even stopped bust didn't
even slow down we have to treat her with
gene therapy
vampires love to like yeah I needed to
draw you out yeah they always just be
running around between things
I said get out of here
oh no if you kill Whistler
whoo
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa do you think
we need your blade yeah we need like a
blade signal maybe like a light with a a
bat I got it
oh boy looks like some jigsaw [__]
oh
no
no yeah
Frost is trying to
trigger up Vampire Apocalypse
vampire God he's trying to resurrect
the earth a key
she needs your blood of course
that's why he wants you alive
oh your girl's working on the Cure
now walk
away oh this is devastating yeah I loved
Whistler
she's making the cure just hang tight
uh by the time you watch this your
friend Whistler should be dead
it's a good thing he played that
afterwards I think that's why they give
him cancer so that we were like okay he
was gonna go anyway yeah
cast of the Silver Bullet yeah you gotta
be prepped for everything
stack them up locked and loaded let's go
I was gonna say this is the most like
somber take on a gearing up Montage yeah
he's like getting a Zenon almost
the sound the music
this is not like let's [__] go this
is like
I guess we gotta do this
bite me
I'll just kill myself
there is no cure baby there is
once human
vampires like you aren't a species you
just infected a virus a sexually
transmitted I'll tell you what we are
assistant
the blood God's coming and after tonight
you people of in history
anyone caught in his path will instantly
be turned it won't matter who's pure
blood and who's not
how you gonna kill the whole world
this does give half blood Vibes it's
like sad yeah I do feel he's the day but
I do feel bad that people keep [__]
on him for not being pure blood it's
like you kind of got it yeah you kind of
get where his bitterness comes from and
I'm like I don't know why go to the
bother of turning people if you're gonna
be this way right
yes come on come on ride your bike in
the house
let's pray in man why am I hearing
gunfire huh
did I tell anybody to start shooting I
need him alive
no assume it's not oh shy is sick Sin
City baby yeah and Terminator
Vamp taser
wow whoa whoa
[Music]
lumpy potatoes
oh my god do you like your potatoes
mashed
like I'm pulverized pureed and otherwise
that was crazy
thank you
this
yeah every time
hey man gotta get the most out of these
tell me the 90s without telling me we're
in the 90s
no
but you died
I came back Eric
and Deacon welcomed me into his arms
no
oh
damn it I should have seen that coming
you spent your whole life looking for
the vampire who bit your mother
here I am oh
uh what a bastard
maybe when we get out of this I'll take
that Miracle cue of yours there's one
catch if it works
you'll be completely human
uh why would you want to be human just
to avoid it sucking a little blood
oh it looks even better in person
making
totally why isn't his mom thinking about
him
indoctrinated to the cause
this made me so sad but still is mommy
mommy mom mama
safety's off what do we have here
the precious serum
how long has it been since your shadow
uh oh
what's it feel like
try it
try some
you might like it
I don't think you'll be needing these
anymore
yes he does you should have listened to
your blood
say what you want
what you want but I promise you you'll
be dead by Dawn Evil Dead too evil does
to me
I'd like you to meet an old friend of
yours
oh
oh no
no she's resourceful she'll get out of
there
can we talk about us I never thought I
would see you again
tell me Karen do you ever have second
thoughts about us
one track mind
damn dude
wow
yes he's gonna grab her legs
yeah very striking
[Music]
it's good they found one just his size
too
yeah I'd look a real idiot in there not
even filling it out
tiptoes
try to understand Eric
your mother died a long time ago
it's time for an edible complex
cute
and I've enjoyed it
how about you
I don't like this moment a little sooner
or later The Thirst always wins
uncomfortable given to The Thirst I was
a literal thirst trap just yeah
are they gonna drain him in that thing
Iron Maiden
new
ouch
like it does look like an Iron Maiden
just like less spikes oh geez oh
bring the elevator up oh dude
[Applause]
yes yeah go save them you ain't no damn
Damsel in Distress neither is he but he
is in distress right now but he's a
damselves go help even if Frost is right
I really think he cares about you
you you're gonna die
it's like the rest of us
oh I can't say stuff like that out loud
man she only has a temper no
self-control wait
is she gonna let him eat her oh maybe
tonight the age of man comes to an end
we're going to be gods
of course
yeah
this is the dawning of the age of LA
magara are you bleeding today
we got no choice gotta try it right now
I want you to take some of my blood
[Music]
oh this is me sexy foreign
ritual oh
okay that's enough that's enough
oh no
well they are shooting this like a sex
scene I know like be a sex scene without
being a sex scene
oh
they could have worked on their blood a
little bit
oh no mom
oh [__]
[Music]
I like the little skeleton flashes
wow not bad I must release you
dang
cool
wow wow that looks crazy
whoa dang shot this pretty smart for
those effects
Dexter
I got two new hands blade I don't know
which one to use to kill you with
we only got one head yeah you got your
glasses back don't take a man's glasses
oh yeah
now we talk and now you're cooking with
gas oh
damn dude
yes the girl fights the other girl as
God intended obviously it's about to be
a what girl for you oh
I'm Really Gonna enjoy this now
no
why is she devil
never get sold did you enjoy it honey
was that good for you was it as good for
you as it was for me
their breakdown's fighting whoa
ouch
blade blade blade blade
it
love that little
where's our girl she's up there
somewhere depleted whoa
whoa
the last few blood damn
yeah
any mouth what the [__] yes he did it's
an interesting call huh
wow
magra must be a lady God
flipping
none of that affects him anymore so what
are we gonna do It's gotta be the garlic
and the silver yeah he's gonna have to
find the world's largest clove of garlic
and put it up his butt
thank you
nice shot
yeah boy you knew that was a great usage
of that excellent work that's a cool
yeah device
is that him
whoa whoa whoa whoa come out some
[__] are always trying to ice
skate uphill
I never heard that I've never heard that
one but I like it
yes
oh my God he looks insane right now yeah
some [__] are always trying to
ice skate uphill that's right I love
when it does this [__]
[Music]
oh it's like Street trash or something
like a bunch of grapes trying to ice
skate uphill
but like is she okay I guess you've seen
enough [__] now that she can hang out a
few more hours before getting that cure
again
or maybe it's different because he's the
day Walker I don't know if it will work
because she already had taken it what
happens when the day Walker feeds on you
there's still a war going on
and I have a job to do
you want to help
make me a better
okay still needs his power he is right
there is a job to do
please
Alex surprises too
[Laughter]
there you go there you go
I was like the equivalent scene right
there that was wicked
[Music]
it's like very obvious why this movie
gets as much love as it does yeah
okay so Donald Logue was the the one guy
damn that went hard
not bad not bad not bad at all that was
legitimate
eight-year-old me is so psyched right
now but do you think it's not bad or you
think it's really good no that was
really good I thought that was super
[__] solid yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
don't don't mistake the tone the tone of
not bad not the words not bad it was
really good like the first of all he is
so badass dude Wesley Snipes all day
like I this makes me wish that they
would somehow Multiverse him in Just
Right totally he's so sexy he's so
badass he's so believable he's a great
actor he delivers those Stone Cold lines
it's like him and Keon who both have
that thing down you know and then and
he'd be throwing down on the it looked
like he was throwing down on a lot of
those stunts if not most all of them
could I have used more of a love story
you know I could have
do I want to see them like passionately
suck face
and just like I would have I would have
been here for it I'm so happy I saved
you yeah I did want to see that I did
but other than that it's Perfection you
want the romance novel cut I do the the
um uh what was Stephen dorff's
character's name from Sunshine Frost
yeah the opposite Sunshine Frost was
Frost was spooky [__] he was he
was crazy good on you Stephen Dorff yeah
he had that perfect he had a good
balance of like yeah being like the
petulant younger guy who nobody takes
seriously but not like an annoying like
he had the right balance where I'm not
like how did this guy get to where he is
right you could see it yeah it was
Friday sometimes yeah he's like just the
right amount of a brat like not too much
to where I'm like I don't believe this
guy but enough that I'm like yeah I see
why you're sort of alienated from
everybody and everyone's always being
like oh you have blood you know you
you're not one of us real vampires man
so like you know I got where his
character came from and I thought yeah
just like because of what vampire lore
is and and this sort of iconography that
you've come to expect I feel like yeah
he embodies that sort of like you know
he's got his sexy fluid thing he's a
little bit Manic and crazed but also you
know he's he's just like a hot young guy
man totally the thing that was cool too
though is that all the vampires are
problematic even the one that he kills
by looking at the sunshine you know like
that guy's obsessed with pure Bloods
yeah I know someone else who is obsessed
with pure blood you know like you never
want like it's not like some of the
vampires were good some of them are bad
it's just pretty much for the most part
it's just blade is good yeah all the
other vampires we see are bad varying
degrees of bad and and have different
motivations right like there's the ones
that want all the vampires to be pure
purebred which is like they're born a
vampire and then there's the Half-Blood
vampires that want vampires to take over
the world and get rid of the humans it's
like different degrees and variations
and steps down and whatnot
yeah absolutely and I like the way that
they unfolded their lore I mean
sometimes you know when you're like in
the heat of a reaction and stuff like
that you got to kind of like collect and
keep all the details straight but I
thought that they did nicely not to like
do too much Exposition dumping while
also kind of letting you get the hang of
like okay so these vampires can
regenerate and okay so there is a
difference between pure blood and turned
vampires oh snap Gary ton of Cliff did a
bunch of the makeup effects I got to uh
do a little uh I got to do a little
shoot with him once that's cool what'd
you do I used to work uh for fangoria
back in the day and we did a show uh
called blood and guts that was later
retitled blood Works where Scott Ian
from Anthrax uh would go to different
effects houses and they would
demonstrate an effect and then do it on
Scott and uh yeah we got to go to Gary
tunnel Cliff's place that's cool at one
point in time that's cool that's a cool
dude uh did you feel like it was a
little some parts dragged a little bit
or you've thought it was good pace
for the most part I thought it was it
was pretty well paced I mean it this is
this is like a two-hour movie and so
part of me I'm fascinated by this
because this came at a time
before what the superhero movie the
comic book movie Etc that we know now
came into full form so I feel like this
did like take its time at moments to
slow down a little bit and to have like
little character beats and stuff uh I
didn't feel like it ever really dragged
that much but there were times where I
was like okay so we're slowing down to
breathe a little bit and and most of the
time when I would notice that it was
during a scene
that I liked I mean I usually I
preferred it more when it's like okay
we're getting to know Whistler a little
bit more okay here's an intimate moment
between Karen and blade or something
like that but uh but yeah I mean it
definitely has sort of a different
approach to the pace in that regard and
it feels like something a bit more out
of the 90s like if you said to me that
you you know were like oh you could
tighten this up by like 10 or 15 minutes
like I yeah I would like argue you
against that but at the same time I'm
not sitting here going like man like
certain parts of the like I liked living
in the world still I'm with you how did
you feel that this compares to other
vampire pieces like taking out the
superhero component of this or whatever
you want to call or the the uh comic
book aspect of this like just focusing
on the supernatural do you feel like
this is a good vampire movie do you like
the way that they dealt with the
vampires and like what their different
looks were how they die how they what
powers they have what hurts them yeah I
like this the lore in the society they
set up quite a a bit actually I mean
yeah you I mean it's part parts of it
are obviously borrowing from the
classics but you know you have this
underground CD World of Vampires that
secretly controls everything like it did
almost remind me of something that could
come like you know a certain I forget
how far in the future something like
daybreakers is set but you know it's
like they got their hands on the cops
and they got you know clearly all these
different Enterprises and stuff like
that and the shadowy cabal of you know
the top vampire families or whatever
that is like I thought all that stuff
was cool and then the ultimate end game
of like we have this vampire Bible and
there's a prophecy and we have to do
this Blood ritual to bring back you know
this ancient Spirit to you know help us
you know
take over the world and or destroy it uh
yeah like I thought it was nice in that
regard and also then bringing in
elements like okay so silver and garlic
those things work stuff like holy water
and Crosses doesn't so much so yeah I
like that they said that they're like
some of that BS and it's like oh yeah
it's like you know not that I'm always
sitting here going like remove the
religious aspect but like that makes
sense to me it's like okay so like this
world yeah the religious or the more
sort of like faith-based uh remedies or
or weapons are not going to be effective
here but there are certain like
science-based things that they use and
even the thing with
trying to figure out the Cure like that
can be you know kind of kind of a silly
thing in movies and and certainly here I
guess it does sort of get resolved
kind of in that one moment where she's
like well if I you know do this the way
we would approach this other you know
disease that I'm aware of you know I can
kind of make at least a cure for people
who have been bit and transformed after
the fact and uh but even that you know I
thought was
I like that they took the time to
differentiate like you know I don't
think it would work on like a purebred
vampire or maybe somebody who's been
gone way too long because that was
another thing too when his mom came back
I was like oh no are they gonna do a
thing where they like try to cure her
from this yeah or something like that
and uh and yeah like I liked the The
Temper the tempering of that I guess but
she didn't know Humanity left in her oh
she did now that you've seen this what
would you want say your dream doing the
blade movie that's coming out now would
you want it to be a sequel to this would
you want it to be a remake of this would
you want them like what was it that you
would want
that's an excellent question because I
think this like you know watching this
in the here and now where
uh obviously you have everything to
compare it to I'm like this is kind of
what I would have wanted from a blade I
know I know it's like weird that we're
watching this now because now it's like
what do I what other thing do I need
yeah and like this also had I I
appreciate this too because this is 1998
you have a lot of obviously practical
gags but a fair amount of CG gags as
well and so all I can imagine at this
moment is like
okay so the effects will look more
smooth and we're in a time and place
where I my main concern with the new
blade is like this did so many things a
with blood gags but also like you had
the big old giant like Glutton creature
and you had like little things like that
that I'd never even seen that image
before I was like what is this dude and
then you had like the the anti-serum
that like you know makes them all like
warp out blow up and and yeah like it is
so kind of pulpy and wild and I am it
makes me a little bit wary just because
I'm like I don't know how this
I'm sure there's a possible way to do it
there's always a way to do it but uh
yeah going
nobody knows yet if it'll be a PG-13 but
that's kind of like the worst case
scenario that you would expect for you
know an MCU bummer
itself for PG-13 the way that the
character needs
yeah but who knows they might be able to
make that work
um it's just such a dark like vampire in
Vampire me fiction media Etc lore is all
kind of carnal and and
sensuous and bloody so yeah I mean you
they've made various PG-13 Vamp movies
but I feel like to really yeah get the
oomph that you want because too I mean
you know I think these comic book
universes have an interesting interplay
as well between you know like DC has a
Constantine where you're going into like
magic and the more hellish side of the
world and it's demons and creatures and
it's sort of removed even though it
makes sense that they would co-exist in
a world with like alien super beings or
people transformed in lab accidents it
still feels like a a sort of separate
side of the world too and I feel like
this would occupy that kind of space in
a place like the MCU and so yeah it's
like almost like elseworlds MCU like
like a little bit or just like their
vertigo whatever their version of that
is because that DC's is like Constantine
Swamp Thing that you know that's they're
like
because they but they even still like
coincide with the other characters like
at least watching some of the animated
movies it's like the first in the DC AMU
continuity they introduce you to
Constantine and etragon and all those
characters via the Justice League at
first so it's like I could see the way
that blade could you know intersect with
the rest of the MCU I mean like I would
be super down for an else world as well
because I feel like you know oftentimes
people Echo the idea of like when you're
less burdened by interconnectivity
things can shine a little brighter but
yeah it's mostly about a sensibility
it's like watching this I could imagine
you know a a modern you know read Redux
of blade or the new take on blade being
maybe a little tighter in terms of that
pace but again I thought it was I I
liked this this was Pace like more of an
actual movie and then you had these
moments with these like crazy speed ramp
gags and stuff like that they put a lot
of Personality into how the world came
across you know yeah I like that you
just use the term personality because it
really did like the way this looked and
sounded had a it was a for lack of
better words just to be as Millennial as
possible for a second it was a total
[__] Vibe yeah it's a total Vibe like
I knew exactly what they were trying to
do what do you think about where we
rented this it says that it's science
fiction suspense compelling downbeat
I mean I love the way they they
categorize these descriptors now I mean
yeah certainly science fiction I mean
there's some suspension like this
actually had some tension I thought you
know even in moments where you can
imagine in your movie math brain how
certain things will work out or not like
I still found myself getting caught up
in things and I thought the impact of
certain uh just perilous moments or
deaths like the whole thing with
Whistler like I really came to like that
character a lot and then when he died
yeah I was sitting there kind of in the
bargaining of like no no there's got to
be a way like damn it but you know
ultimately and it gives him the gun man
yeah
and then I'm like did they did he like
run back there to grab it yeah
but what would you want from an MCU
blade having seen this now I just don't
really know first of all who could do
this as well as Wesley did it
I mean I like mahershal Ali is great and
I have faith in him but also Wednesday
Snipes like because there is like a sort
of grind houseness about this too and I
feel like Wesley Snipes is like a great
call to bring that flavor to life yeah
it's it's nothing against anybody it's
just like this was he's so great in this
Wesley's so great in this that it's like
I'm not looking for something different
but we need to be looking for something
different because we don't want martial
law to just do a Wesley yeah you know so
like yeah what's going to be the spin
and then I I don't know like is it
does blade and the girl that I wanted to
see him get on with do they do they have
a pure blood kid like like do they try
to teach them what happens you know the
the day Walker yeah it creates with a
human
well she's not well I guess she is
she could be a half blood though he just
sucked on her again I know but she can
curious I think they said she can cure
herself again
um but no I can't tell what the actual
story I would need to be and I I haven't
read any of the blade comics so I don't
know like who are who else is in our
sandbox to play with yeah so yeah but I
I'm not not looking forward to it
because it's somewhat of a simple
premise and I love vampire stories well
that's the thing is I feel like yeah
thinking about what new blade could be
is just sort of like I don't know I
guess it would just be a blade movie
kind of like what we just sucks but just
with new faces and I wouldn't ultimately
be upset by that because I don't know
yes you're gonna have slightly different
characters villains different storyline
Etc like so I feel like this is a solid
enough blueprint and they don't really
they can tweak but they don't really
need to tweak a whole lot to you know
didn't they have a director on the
project and then they pulled them that
project has been retooled a lot they had
I think the director left I think
they've gotten different writers on it
and now we have the writer strike going
on so yeah that movie is seems like it's
having a particularly bumpy journey to
fruition bummer but this was legit man I
I really yeah this is after so many
years of trying this this really uh yeah
it had I think like some of the best
elements of 90s cheese but also watching
it you know so many years removed and
I'm like still holds up man totally yeah
like this doesn't feel like I have to
give it too many handicaps for being you
know of a certain time and place yeah
there's like one or two throughout where
we were like oh where'd the sound go
there like okay the way that looks but
for the most part it just was really
solid for a 98 Super solid yeah it just
feels like you know the nightlife is
really Vivid and the effect like I
thought they smartly shot most of the
effects so that yeah like even when the
CG is not like up to Modern standards
the scene still works and it's like you
know those skeleton you know flying
skeleton demon monsters that come out at
the end yeah a little sick looking they
don't look photo real but they look
great yeah like like as they're coming
out of the the people's mouths yeah like
for how they chose to shoot that and
light that and how they you know
animated and captured it like yeah I
just thought this had a lot of energy
and a lot of punch it says downbeat and
like yeah it is a little dreary but I
thought it still had a pulse and it
still had that kind of I guess that's it
it's like I'm interested to see what the
MCU does but I'm glad that this had like
its Edge on it because I feel like it
needs to it is the dark side so it can't
be as like I I would rather see downbeat
as the descriptor then yeah totally I
think that uh the good thing about when
they do this what I always try to remind
myself the good thing about when they do
like the next blade is that this one
still exists it doesn't take that and
and put it in the trash so there will
always be this so
to this too yeah yeah it'll be
interesting to see what they do with it
yeah yeah
good action it's just one right designs
of this yeah no they're three three I
thought there was just one more I
thought it was blade one and two there's
blade three Blade Trinity yeah
I forgot
there it is a Trilogy and the third one
is called braid Blade Trinity wow braid
Trinity and one of them has like Ryan
Reynolds and I think one of them was in
fact I think I think I've heard it said
that the Ryan Reynolds one is is like
he's the one good part of that Sequel
and I think maybe like Blade Two or
something people like it's kind of
underrated and I think like Guillermo
del toross no no I mean Blade Trinity is
definitely a thing does he make it out
alive
of Blade Trinity
I don't know any of the blades
I saw two and three but never the first
no no you know but uh I mean I would
love to I would love to continue the
journey I would love to see how this
world evolves and how they you know
because this was also Yeah a different
time where like franchising things
wasn't quite as streamlined obviously as
it is now
um but this is a world that I would like
be totally psyched to come back to I'd
be totally psyched to see a different
take on a different city like I love the
way they captured the city and there's
just so much to do with a world like
this and I mean not that other vampire
stories haven't explored that stuff but
you know it's like with the different
casts of vampires pure blood turned this
daywalker situation seems like there's a
lot you could explore with that
definitely and they put like a lot of
moving Parts which is good not too many
but a lot that we could explore yeah and
like these other like more feral looking
creatures like the guy the you know lab
the nurse the lab tech the guy she's
working with who she doesn't want to
talk about their past relationship like
it seemed like they'd been like starving
him and he was turning into like a
sickly sort of creature
um so yeah it's like one of those movies
where I feel like it's it's rounded for
the story they're telling but it also
just hints at more stuff you know beyond
the periphery
um so yeah I don't know I thought the
cast did really really nice job overall
I'm with you uh Wesley Snipes freaking
killing it whoever uh what is her name
who played Karen I thought she did a
good job she was excellent and uh and
that was like a nice
um you know it's like I was rooting for
that love story and I I am often these
days being like I want a little more
like actual romance in these things
big make out at the end I wanted yeah
your face sucks I wanted a little little
like ending vampire orgy
Ivy that's the thing is like you know
vampire stuff is like trademark sexy I
know so I know I watched all Vampire
Diaries and The Originals listen I
watched all of Buffy she was a Slayer
that's true this is really good but you
know
that was a soap opera that brought back
the The Craze of vampires and theme song
was Tainted Love oh
my baby returned here alone which is a
cover I never knew Soft Cell did not
write that song oh who did oh I'd have
to dig back I used to know this reach
deep but yeah it's like one of those
songs that was like written for I think
it was written for like a female singer
or something like that like you know a
couple decades prior and then yeah and
then they did the cover I never saw any
of the Twilight movies
ah I've seen one or two I never saw them
uh I feel like
did this do vampires better
don't go to Twilight if what you want is
vampire lore what's your favorite
vampire movie
oh that's a great question oh I would
have to think
um
Jesus I always lean towards like classic
stuff like I always I've watched like
Nosferatu every every year I mean I I
have it could be better in places but I
really like daybreakers like when the
when the vampire craze was really going
down that was a movie I was uh quite
enamored by there's one called a girl
walks home alone at night that's pretty
cool do you like of werewolf zombies
vampires what's your jam
a root for werewolf because they're like
underdone I feel like
um
ah I probably find I probably would say
vampire just pound for pound I feel like
there's the I mean there are a lot of
great zombie movies
um there it seems like as I'm trying to
think there's more vampire TV shows but
I feel like there's more zombie movies
than vampire movies
is that wrong
there's I mean I would be fascinated to
know the answer because it does seem
like there are there there are hordes of
zombie movies as as you know innumerable
as the actual hordes within them um but
I feel like vampire is like well trodden
and and goes back probably longer uh has
has greater longevity probably than the
zombie story
[Music]
and I haven't seen like I haven't seen
like uh Let the Right One In
which I know people love
um let's see okay
um Renfield was just good oh I wanted to
see that I I uh I've heard good things
I've never seen Interview with a Vampire
feel like people are loving the TV show
right now I watched the first couple
episodes it was good yeah
um I guess Nosferatu I feel like like a
like a cop-out saying that I mean what
we do in the shadows is great if you
like a movie or the show better
for what we do in the shadows yeah uh I
guess probably the movie but I like the
show just as much
fright night's pretty good I haven't
seen the uh the remake of fright night
but uh
but yeah From Dusk Till Dawn that's a
great vampire movie that might be a time
I've missed a lot of these a topper and
you both of us have not seen underworld
Ah that's right yeah and I feel like I
think that one has both has both
vampires and uh werewolves if I'm not
mistaken
uh but yeah what's your favorite vampire
movie I don't know I'm I'm you know I'm
a TV girly when it comes to a lot of
these like sure nerdy things yeah so
do we count Buffy as a vampire show yeah
definitely it's in the title I mean you
know there are other monsters but I feel
like vampires are like a Mainstay of you
know that one Slayer that's right
this is good [__] man I like this a lot
I I would be thrilled to see more of the
blade universe and uh and yeah like I
just want to soak up all the Wesley
Snipes because this this does seem like
one of those instances and I don't have
like the greatest experience with blade
comics but he seems like a like a
terrific
choice to bring a character like this to
life and especially with how much you
can tell he's really thrown down like
you know he seems like the perfect like
action star vehicle that's also like
nice and gooey and horary and and just
yeah like the vampire nightclub and
stuff like that there's so many cool
like you know little flourishes
[Music]
we've been watching good stuff together
that's a thumbs up good luck charm you
got any more stray thoughts before we
skedaddle because of the braids right
man because braid rhymes with blade
that's right blade Trinity over here
oh yeah I hope I hope it watches so we
can watch the next one yeah I hope
I would love that I would love to at
least watch the the agreeable ones you
know I know people I know there's at
least one that people don't like so much
but uh you know I think how bad could it
be it's with Wesley ah right yeah
totally and I mean I'm sure there are
other like crazy uh guess uh you know
supporting actors that I don't know
about to surprise us too that's crazy
that's right man I I think that's again
this is like the one part of that movie
I've heard is good do you have closing
thoughts
no just uh just want more I just want
you know I wanna this was vital you know
and uh I'm glad to have finally like I
said this movie has been built up over
so much time for me because of that
specific experience it's like yeah I
begged and begged we went and yeah like
the second they got into the class just
I knew because I yeah it's like okay
she's mom's on the floor she grabbed
that dude's crotch blood sprinkler and
like those are the three images I
remember from my youth so having that
paid off now and I tried to actually
watch it again years later with a friend
who I hadn't seen in a long time and and
we went to put it on and just wound up
talking to each other like and not even
you know engaging with any movies so
like yeah after so long this was like a
triumphant you know dunk well you did it
I didn't have to like work to enjoy this
is good
quite quite delightful what did you guys
think leave us your thoughts down below
be very excited to hear what y'all think
about this and if you want us to check
out any more of the Blade franchise
heading into the MCU version and uh yeah
much love to y'all check us out on
patreon if you want to get the full
experience and last but not least let's
do a page
kale Linden
my dude I think we should attend a
vampire party together I think that
would be good McHale's out in uh in
Sweden oh I feel like they'd have good
vampires in Sweden yeah man I feel like
the vampires in Sweden like you know I
feel like I watch a lot of like you know
American vampire movies or early vampire
movies set in America and everyone just
kind of like sleazed out all the time
like I feel like Swedish vampires would
be a little bit more poised a little bit
more genial do you think that they are
sweeter in Sweden they are they are the
Swedish
Mikhail is the sweetest of all yeah he's
a he is a sugary uh delightful Swedish
Fish he's a Swedish Fish
I love Swedish fish do they come from
Sweden Mikhail let us know the history
of Swedish Fish and let us know how many
Americans ask you about this yeah
because they're very popular here are
they just called fish in Sweden let us
know and uh yeah hope you're out there
doing well we appreciate you being you
were your support of this patreon is
goes back so far it's like you are you
know like part of an ancient lineage of
super sexy pjx oh so you know damn yeah
so if ever we need to do some kind of
blood ritual to awaken like the prime
ordeal reject of the nation you know you
will be the high priest for that I think
it's a good combo sweet and sexy
sexy Mikhail we love you